DON DODGE: Hi.
I'm Don Dodge.
And this is Google Root Access.
Today my guess is Jay Simons,
president of the Atlassian.
Jay, we had you here last week
to talk about the enterprise
software model and
how that worked.
Great show.
Wanted to invite you
back again this week
to talk about how Atlassian
started, because it's
quite an interesting story.
So, started in 2002
in Sydney, Australia.
JAY SIMONS: Yep.
2002, Sidney, Australia.
I wasn't actually
there at the time.
My accent betrays that probably.
The two founders, both
engineers, both developers,
and actually the
beginning of the company
they were supporting an open
source application server
call Orion.
And they were doing technical
support for that product,
and actually doing
customization for customers
all over the world.
And they, I think at the time,
were using an open source issue
tracker, Bugzilla, and
became frustrated with it.
And so built their own.
And like most software startups,
shared it with their friends.
And their friends-- who were
developers in other companies--
said, man, I would love to
use that instead of Bugzilla
or Tracker, whatever I
was using at the time.
And they said,
why then would you
pay for something like that?
Of course I would.
So in the early days, they
went from in their network
of people, and they were pretty
active in the Java community
at the time, their network
of other developers
and other companies and had
heard just a resounding need
for something like JIRA.
And JIRA was that first product.
And so they did
the famous pivot,
and moved from, effectively,
a service and support
company to a software company
in the early beginnings.
They had a product
that actually had legs.
And so that was the
beginning of Atlassian.
DON DODGE: So it
started from day one,
charging a subscription for the
product, right from day one.
JAY SIMONS: We charged
licensing the software.
In the early days, it
wasn't available in cloud.
It was just something
that you install therein
in your own servers.
And it was licensed.
It was somewhere between
$1,000 and $5,000,
depending on the edition.
But it was intentionally
priced to be very affordable.
And if you think about
where they started,
they started in Sidney.
And they realized actually
that most of the market
is an ocean away from then.
And they had a choice
to either hire people
in each of those markets
and try to represent
the software, the company,
that they were trying to build,
or figure out whether they
could use the internet
to reach those customers
in foreign markets
and other markets.
And they chose the latter.
And it was a pretty
methodical approach
to building one brick
on top of another
and figuring out how could, A,
how could they build awareness
for the company and the
product, how could they
reach those markets,
and then how could they
enable those customers to
try the product themselves
and then buy it if
they deem that it
was suitable for the job.
DON DODGE: So many
founders today
believe they need to
be in Silicon Valley
to start a company.
And Atlassian was started
in Sydney, Australia.
Many founders believe
that they need
to give the product away or have
some type of a freemium model
to get started.
But Atlassian glassy and started
with a straight up license.
Do you think you could
do the same thing today
in today's environment?
JAY SIMONS: I absolutely
think you can.
There's a lot of
examples, I think,
of companies that start
today without freemium
but are affordable.
And I think you need to think
very carefully about pricing,
right?
If pricing is very high,
it's a barrier, right?
It's an obstacle
that you're going
to have to figure out a way to
convince your customers to jump
over with you.
Oftentimes, companies
do that with sales.
And sales works
to do that, right?
You can understand a
customer's paying point
and have a conversation
about whether or not
you can solve it, and
understand whether or not
they're willing to do a
value exchange for what
you want to charge that.
And that works, tried and true.
But you could also very early
days in very early beginnings
figure out whether or not you
can build a pricing model that
reduces the that friction
point or that obstacle
for your customers.
And you need to
be careful to make
sure that that model
scales in the way
that you want it to over time.
And maybe that's hard, right?
Because it's, in some cases,
you are making some assumptions.
And my only advice is be
careful about the assumptions
that you make and
think about how
you'd want to scale
them over two or three
or four years from
now, if you're
successful at a
lower entry point.
DON DODGE: So Atlassian is
really an amazing story,
because you broke all the rules.
You didn't come to Silicon
Valley, started in Sydney.
You didn't do a freemium
model or give away.
You charged a
license right away.
You didn't raise
venture capital.
You were able to bootstrap
and become cash flow positive.
Talk about that a little bit.
How were you able to be cash
flow positive and still grow?
JAY SIMONS: Well, if you think
about when the company started,
it was 2002.
So it was right after
the dot com crash.
So it was probably
very difficult for two
technical founders in Sydney,
Australia to raise money
and to begin with.
And so, their option was, well,
let's just do it on our own.
I mean, they probably could have
tried to come to Silicon Valley
and raise money in
an environment that
really wasn't conducive to it.
Or they could just roll up
their sleeves and get to work.
And so that's why
they chose to do.
So, took out a line of
credit on a credit card
and, you know, bootstraps,
where they didn't pay themselves
a lot of money.
They worked
incredibly long hours.
They built a product that
they felt they was something
that they could build
a business around.
They validated that with
their early customers.
And then they just kept on
building the business one
hand after another.
And when they started
to make money,
they put the money back into the
business versus their own bank
accounts.
They were very frugal.
I think the DNA
of the company is
to be very, very
conscious about spending
and think about
return, and think
about building a business that's
going to be here 5, 10, 15, 50
years from now, versus
one that you're just
going to build for today.
And I think that DNA,
because of our two founds,
it permeates through
the business even today.
DON DODGE: And then
the fourth accepted
practice, stock options
for employees, Atlassian
didn't offer stock
options either.
JAY SIMONS: Not until 2010.
And largely that was because
in Australia, there's
a different association
with equity than there
that's typical than the
value Australians actually
are taxed a grant.
And so in some ways, there's
a negative association
with equity.
You're saying, hey,
here's something
that is potentially
not worth anything.
But it has a value today
that you have to pay tax on.
And so I'm giving you
something that actually
is going to cost you
money out of your pocket.
And it's very uncommon there.
And that's just culturally
it wasn't really accepted.
And which is why
we didn't have it.
DON DODGE: Wow.
So there's four things
that startups typically
do in Silicon Valley
when they start.
And Atlassian did none of them.
So maybe starting in Australia
and starting with that mindset
was actually an advantage
that people or founders
in Silicon Valley don't have.
JAY SIMONS: I absolutely
think it's an advantage.
I think it was an
advantage for us.
Like, it can be an advantage.
I mean. there's
tons of companies.
If you look like Rovio is
a great company that I like
to use in example, in Helsinki,
that built Angry Nerds.
And again I think there are
numerous examples of companies
that spring out of whatever
environment they're in.
And I think that environment is
a petri dish to do new things
and break conventions.
DON DODGE: So eight years
of profitability and growth
from 2002 didn't raise any
venture capital no stock
options fully licensed
and now subscription.
And then in 2010, a big change.
You raise $60 million
of venture capital.
That's a pretty big shift.
So what went into that decision?
JAY SIMONS: So we'd
just gone through
the 2009 global
financial crisis.
And made a couple
of big decisions
just to swing for the
fences coming out of that.
So when everyone
else was downsizing,
we ended up growing by 50%.
And we did this
big hiring binge.
When everyone else was worried
about maintaining growth,
we actually made the entry
point for our products
free at that time.
So we could make it more
affordable for companies
in the pension 2009.
And then I thought, we
thought, very carefully
about the business that
we wanted to build,
and decided that we wanted to
build a company that was going
to be here growing and
a venerable concern 50
years from today.
We wanted to be the next
Oracle, or the Salesforce.com,
or replace those two companies.
And when you think about
what that journey entails,
you plot out a couple of
gates you want to run through.
And I think one of them
is to be a public company.
If you back up from
that, to go there
we probably should
have an early investor,
somebody's who's going to
partner with us over the three
years, ramping up to
that point or the years
ramping up to that point.
And so we decided
to basically take
an investor and a partner
who would help build
the business over the
next 3 to 50 years.
DON DODGE: So Atlassian
has been contrarian almost
from the beginning.
All of the accepted beliefs
of how you build a company,
Atlassian went against the
grain almost every time.
And the last example,
raising $60 million in 2010
when everyone else
was hunkering down
and trying to recover
from the financial crisis,
you're out there raising
money and hiring people.
So what's next?
JAY SIMONS: Yeah, you
know, the concerning thing,
it could another--
what do they say,
they say the toilets spin the
other direction in Australia,
and maybe it has
something to do with that?
What's next for us?
We're continuing just
to focus on growth.
And we announced,
I think, a couple
of really exciting products
recently, one JIRA Service
Desk, which expands the
market that we can support
for collaboration beyond
software teams to IT teams.
I think that's an important
and big, bold move for us.
We also announced an enterprise
Quora confluence questions,
which is an Enterprise-grade
Q&A product that I think
takes the pattern that Quora
and Stack Overflow have
demonstrated on the internet
and provides that to customers.
And so I think there's a
number of exciting new product
initiatives.
And we've got 30,000
active customers now,
and I think there's
hundreds to millions
more that we could go support.
And that's what we're chasing.
DON DODGE: So another example.
Quora and Stack
Overflow are free.
And I suspect that
your product is
a paid license or subscription?
JAY SIMONS: It is, although
neither of those products
are really used by enterprises.
And so we're a business
software company,
where we're taking, I
think, great patterns that
exist on the internet
or just in open source
or just in commercial
source and trying
to make better experiences
that are more affordable
and provide better
value to customers.
And that's sort of the
DNA of the company.
DON DODGE: Wow.
An amazing story.
So thank you very
much for joining us.
I want to remind you, if
you're a cloud developer,
we're offering a $2,000
credit for Google Cloud.
The details on how you
can sign up for that
remain on your screen right now.
Thank you very much for joining
us, and see you next time.